à montigny le bretonneux le maire
sortant divers droite jean luc bourgault
ne se représentera pas en mars prochain
il avait pour rappel succéder à michel
laugier devenu sénateur des yvelines en
2017 et pour conduire la liste de la
majorité alimentent n lorrain amércaine
bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous conduirait la liste montigny
ensemble une première candidature
candidature pour vous vous avez été
directeur de cabinet sur les mandats des
maires de nicolas bour michel laugier et
jean-luc hugo pourquoi sortir de l'ombre
en quelques sortes et vous lancer dans
cette démarche eh bien je pense que au
fil de toutes ces années où j'ai appris
à connaître la ville à gérer des
dossiers très importants et a rencontré
aussi beaucoup d'habitants lorsque l'on
cumule cette expérience il ya un moment
dans la vie de chacun ou franchi une
étape et on sent prêt pour passer à
autre chose et ce rendez vous du 15 mars
arrive pour moi comme le moment en
parfaite adéquation avec ça c'est le
moment pour moi d'y aller je pense une
expérience qui remonte à 2001 vous avez
presque 20 ans du coup d'expérience à ce
poste que vous at il à pris ce poste
et à quoi ça vous ça va vous servir dans
cette aspiration à devenir mère
justement le poste de directeur de
cabinet j'ai pu m'en rendre compte en
discutant avec des habitants encore tout
récemment tout le monde ne sait pas
forcément très bien ce que c'est c'est
le premier collaborateur du maire c'est
donc celui qui est en charge de mettre
en musique en application la politique
avec l'administration
c'est celui aussi qui est le relais avec
les partenaires institutionnels
l'agglomération la préfecture et bien
sûr qui est aussi en lien avec les
habitants les associations
donc ça permet à la fois d'avoir une
vision précise de la ville des enjeux
qui peuvent se poser pour la ville de
connaître les dossiers structurants qui
la concerne et en même temps d'acquérir
une connaissance à la fois des quartiers
et des personnes pour pouvoir mener à
bien ensuite une fonction d'élu local
dans le cadre de ma fonction j'ai
toujours été sur le terrain j'ai
toujours dès le départ en soirée sur les
week-ends voulu m'impliquer dans la vie
associative dans la vie des quartiers
parce que je crois que
la fonction de d'élu local c'est
vraiment une fonction on doit d'abord
être au contact des habitants le contact
direct
c'est aussi la façon de faire des mères
que j'ai accompagné et c'est aussi la
façon de faire de l'équipe qui a choisi
de me faire confiance pour la conduire
aux prochaines élections je sens cette
équipe est ce que elle est uniquement
l'héritière de la majorité sortante vous
avez souhaité tout de même apporté
quelques nouveaux visages au sein de
cette église damman il faut renouveler
une équipe c'est très important
il faut pouvoir mais les expériences
parce que la gestion d'une ville est de
plus en plus complexes les dossiers sont
de plus en plus difficile à monter et
donc il faut des gens qui est une
certaine expérience
mais en même temps il ya un vrai besoin
d'avoir un regard neuf qui viennent
s'ajouter à cela
donc j'ai souhaité renouveler à 50%
l'équipe à peu près de façon à pouvoir
mixer ces deux éléments
une liste que vous revendiquez sans
étiquette même si vous êtes plutôt de
sensibilité centriste alors c'est
absolument moi je suis centriste je n'ai
jamais été encarté dans aucun parti
la liste que je conduis est une liste
d'ouverture
elle a toujours été historiquement une
liste dans laquelle on comptait une
bonne proportion que l'on qualifie de
centre-droit mais elle a toujours été
ouverte et elle a toujours été elle a
toujours accueilli des gens d'autres
sensibilités et surtout aussi beaucoup
de gens qui ne sont pas encartés comme
moi mais qui avait envie de faire des
choses pour leur vie mais est-ce que
d'éventuels soutiens par exemple du
parti des républicains de lui des hits
je sais qu'il y aussi des discussions
avec la république en marche est ce que
vous les accepteriez ses soutiens
effectivement je n'ai pas sollicité mois
de soutien auprès d'aucun parti par
contre certains partis m'ont fait
l'honneur de m'apporter leur soutien
gg ainsi le soutien de l'ue dei par
exemple le soutien des républicains
je n'ai pas sollicité le soutien de la
république en marche non plus
effectivement j'ai pu avoir des
discussions avec eux mais encore une
fois ce qui m'intéresse avant tout c'est
de prendre avec moi des personnes qui
ont envie de se mobiliser pour leur
ville alors pour avec cette équipe il y
aura il y aura trois priorités ans pour
votre programme tout d'abord la
transition écologique qui est un point
que l'on voit revenir souvent dans de
nombreux programmes c'est un point sur
lequel il faut compter pour pour ces
élections ne peut pas faire sans
aujourd'hui non je crois que c'est
devenu totalement incontournable c'est
pas une question de parti ça n'est pas
une question d'idéologie
on est bien conscient qu'aujourd'hui on
arrive à un moment où il faut que les
modes de vie changent et donc là-dessus
effectivement je les ai évoqué lors de
la réunion de lancement
je souhaite vraiment que nous puissions
à un travail sur ce sujet très important
parce que il faut que la ville puisse
accompagner ces changements tout ne peut
pas se faire au niveau d'une ville mais
on doit être un acteur incontournable de
de cela et je crois qu'on a la capacité
de le faire on a tout d'abord la
possibilité d'agir dans chacune de nos
politiques publiques en veillant à ce
que pour chacune d'entre elles
on est bien la notion de transition
écologique qui soit intégrée dans les
critères de choix et ensuite on a aussi
par le biais de l'exemplarité par le
biais de la sensibilisation par le biais
du faire ensemble des choses qu'une
ville s'est portée avec ses habitants le
moyen de d'accompagner cette transition
écologique et de faire tout notre
possible contribuer à notre échelle en
tout cas pour que les choses puissent
évoluer favorablement sur ce sujet il ya
un autre thème sur lequel les habitants
sont de plus en plus attachés c'est la
sécurité puisque vous prévoyez sur sur
ce thème sur la sécurité
alors évidemment montigny n'est pas la
ville qui présente le plus de grands de
problèmes de sécurité aujourd'hui pour
autant
montigny ne vit pas dans une bulle et on
a des problèmes d'incivilité et parfois
de délinquance comme partout et ce que
l'on peut constater c'est que quels que
soient les gouvernements la réponse est
insuffisante et l'expérience que j'ai au
fil de ses 19 années c'est que
finalement c'est le maire qui est le
lien entre l'état et les citoyens qui
doit être en première ligne sur ce sujet
et qui doit mettre sa connaissance à la
fois des partenaires mais aussi des
quartiers et des personnes pour pouvoir
mettre en place et en mettre en oeuvre
les bons dispositif pour pouvoir agir
sur les problèmes d'insécurité et donc
c'est vraiment pour moi quelque chose de
très important et qui doit se faire
aussi en contact avec les habitants qui
sont les premiers concernés ont fait
déjà ce travail aujourd'hui on travaille
beaucoup avec des amicales de locataires
par exemple qui sont pour moi des
partenaires incontournables car ce sont
eux qui ont la connaissance de ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers et c'est à
leurs côtés qu'on souhaite mener cette
politique
alors ça c'était pour le 2e pilier le
troisième pilier c'est la réhabilitation
du secteur dit de l'hyper centre autour
de la gare saint quentin en yvelines la
ville et l'agglomération ont lancé une
concertation pour la rénovation de ce
quartier qui a été achevé on le rappelle
en 1987 et qui est jugé aujourd'hui
vieillissant pourquoi certains portent
un projet important pour la ville et
comment finalement rendre ce quartier
plus attractif alors vous l'avez dit
effectivement c'est un quartier qui a
beaucoup vieilli il connaît beaucoup de
beaucoup d'usagers il concentre et ce
aussi énormément de choses et à l'époque
de sa conception favorisent-elles
minérales ont favorisé l'automobile
aussi
aujourd'hui les gens aspirent à plus de
végétal à plus de l'espace piétonnier et
aussi à ce que l'on puisse créer des
lieux de convivialité
donc il ya nécessité de travailler sur
tous ces sujets et sur ces sujets là
nous avons souhaité lancer une
concertation avec la communauté
d'agglomération en associant les
habitants
parce que c'est un quartier économique
un quartier étudiant très important mais
c'est aussi un quartier d'habitation et
donc il faut que les habitants soient
concernés par le sujet pourquoi aussi
nous souhaitons temps faire évoluer ce
quartier c'est parce que on a pu voir
ces dernières années qu'en faisant de
gros efforts sur la gare en faisant des
efforts sur les espaces publics qui
jouxte la gare
on a vu immédiatement dernier
des opérations importantes pouvoir se
faire comme la transformation de
l'immeuble internationale celle de
l'immeuble de la poste
donc on comprend bien que quand la
collectivité investit sur l'espace
public et réalise des espaces qualitatif
ça entraîne derrière des mutations
importantes y compris dans le privé
aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu très fort sur
le centre commercial on le sait tous et
je pense que notre rôle à nous villes et
intercommunalités
c'est de faire ce qu'il faut au niveau
des espaces publics à la fois pour le
rendre le quartier plus agréable pour
les habitants mais en même temps plus
accueillant pour les gens qui viennent
travailler là et incité également les
privés à pouvoir faire évoluer aussi
leur patrimoine
il nous reste quelques secondes vos
prochains rendez vous de campagne que
alors nous l ont tracté sur les
différentes places de la ville le
premier week-end de février
il y aura également une réunion publique
à nouveau à la salle jacques brel
le 26 février où j'espère que nous
accueillons autant de monde que la
semaine dernière
et puis ensuite nous continuerons de
tracter jusqu'à là jusqu'à l'élection
merci laurent marc keller tête de liste
de montigny ensemble représentant de la
majorité sortante et face à vous pour ce
scrutin au moins deux autres listes
montini solidarité conduite par l'ancien
conseiller municipal d'opposition pierre
déjean et la liste m conduite par un
binôme le conseiller municipal
d'opposition actuelle un vivien gasc et
également avec caroline ce chaos